- Our final session for this
morning is on social robots
and will be moderated by
Professor Elena Glassman, who
is Stanley A. Marks and
William H. Marks Assistant
Professor at the
Radcliffe Institute,
and assistant professor of
computer science at Harvard.
And she specializes precisely
on human-computer interaction.
- I'll just start here.
We're going to talk
about social robots.
We have three wonderful
women who have
agreed to be part of our panel.
It's a huge honor to
be here, by the way.
This is the first
time I've gotten
to officially
participate in an event
with the Radcliffe
Institute, which
is going to be a home for me
in a few years as a fellow.
It's a wonderful program, which
I encourage you to look at.
Anyway, we have three
lovely panelists--
Susan, Noel, and Cynthia.
Susan is a singer, voice actor,
and speaker, whose voice you
may recognize from many
different voice services
that we interact with.
Cynthia is an
associate professor
at the MIT Media Lab, where she
has founded the Personal Robots
Group.
And Noel is passionate
about mindful
leadership, work-life
harmony, and empowering people
through emerging technology.
She currently joins us
here from Microsoft.
So without further ado, I will
let our first speaker, Susan,
take the floor.
[APPLAUSE]
Whoops.
Sorry.
- Hello.
Thank you so much for
having me here today.
I feel like I know a
lot of you already.
How many of you have iPhones
or have ever spoken to Siri?
- [INAUDIBLE].
- I thought I recognized you.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, of course, I'm
not really Siri.
I am a singer, voice actor,
and the original voice of Siri.
And how that happened
remains a mystery.
Apple has never really disclosed
how the voice was selected.
But I can give you a little
back story on all of us
so-called disembodied voices
like Siri, Alexa, Cortana, et
cetera.
Now, there are real humans
behind those voices--
voice actors like myself.
And the recordings
that we did that became
part of these applications
are called IVR recordings--
interactive voice response.
And basically, we
had to read thousands
of phrases and
sentences that were
created to get all of the sound
combinations in the language.
After the recordings were done,
technicians and computers went
into the recordings
and extracted sounds,
re-formed these sounds into
new phrases and sentences,
and these are what ended up
on our devices as a Siris
and Alexas, et cetera--
answers to our questions.
Now this amazing process
is called concatenation.
I thought it was
an invented term,
but who knew it's a
regular English word found
in the dictionary.
And it means linking
things together,
which is what they
did with the sounds
that they extracted
from the recordings.
Now the scripts for these
recordings were very strange.
They were created just
for sound, and not
at all for content or meaning.
So they were pretty
wacky, and I've
got a few that I'd
like to share with you.
The phrases you
are about to hear
are actual phrases that I had
to read that ultimately became
part of the voice of Siri.
[? Cow ?] [? hoist ?] in the
[? tub ?] [? hut ?] today.
[INAUDIBLE] fresh issue today.
[? Fossa ?] [? ask ?]
[? fussy. ?] Say the
[? shrodding ?] again,
say the [? shriding ?] again,
say the [? shreeding ?] again,
say the shredding again, say
the [? shrudding ?] again.
[CHUCKLES] Tedious stuff,
especially when you consider
that the initial recordings
were done in 2005-- for me--
four hours a day, five days
a week, for an entire month.
Now the tedium continues
on the other end,
I'm sure, trying to
extract those sounds
and make new sentences.
But I have to say, I think the
people working on the Siri app
probably had more fun than
some of the other voices,
because Siri, especially
the original voice,
was quite a character.
Yes, she had a lot of attitude.
She was feisty, she was
funny, and she could
be quite acerbic at times.
The very first time I ever
spoke to Siri, I said, hi, Siri,
what are you doing?
And she very disgustedly
replied, I'm talking to you.
[LAUGHTER]
So IVR recordings
are only one aspect
of the voiceover
business, which is
what we call the
careers of voice actors,
and it really runs the gamut.
We've got things like radio
and TV commercials, promos,
movie trailers,
animation, gaming,
there are narrations for
film and TV, et cetera.
And those of us who do
this work for a living
are basically freelancers.
And, of course,
freelancers is just
a nice word for saying
we never know where
our next job is coming from.
We have to audition for all
of the work that we get.
So it makes a lot
of sense for us
to be as versatile as possible
so that we can not only
get a lot of auditions,
but hopefully
win a lot of auditions
and have some work.
So it's important for
us to be able to make
a lot of different sounds,
have different accents,
or perhaps even have
whole characters
that we invent, perhaps
like the Evil Queen.
What a lovely group
we have here today.
Why don't you come closer?
Come closer.
I'd like to cast my
evil spell on you.
There's the little elf, Star.
Hi, my name is Star.
I live up at the North Pole
with Santa and Mrs. Clause.
Would you like you like to
come visit me there sometime?
You would?
Oh, boy!
There's the ancient
tree, Conifer.
Oh, I'm so delighted you came
to see me in my forest today.
I've so enjoyed
our conversation.
Oh, I hope you come back
soon, because, you know,
most of the trees around here
just don't have much to say.
There is one of my
all time favorites--
New York Event Planner
[? Shaka ?] Cohen.
Hello, darling.
I do it all-- weddings, bar
mitzvahs, birthday parties--
any event you can think
of darling, call me.
Now the power of the voice can
be incredible sometimes, right?
It's a very powerful
means of communication.
And so what if Siri had
[? Shaka's ?] voice?
I think that would be a
whole new iPhone experience.
[LAUGHTER]
Hello.
What do you want?
Ugh, what am I wearing?
What are you wearing?
And then there's Siri.
Now when I did the recordings
that ultimately became Siri,
I did not really know
what I was doing,
and I have talked to
other IVR actors who
have had the same experience.
We thought that we were
recording generic voicing
for phone systems.
Now you could call
Siri a phone system,
but of course, she is
so much more than that.
She's basically, really, the
first public manifestation
of AI, and certainly
the first concatenated
voice that sounded human
that you could interact with,
that you could communicate with.
Now the tricky thing
about verbal communication
is that it's pretty important
that we be understood,
and that is not always
the case with Siri.
Siri does not always
understand what we say,
no matter how
articulate we can be.
And she doesn't always come up
with the appropriate response.
How many times has she sent
you in the wrong direction?
But she'll do that--
she thinks it's funny.
Now, where was I?
This happens to me every time.
All I can say is,
I'm 70 years old,
short term memory loss is real.
Let me just find my place again.
Gosh, it was going so well.
Communications.
Yes.
When we can't
communicate effectively,
we do get frustrated.
And so I have to
caution you, though--
if you get really, really
frustrated with Siri, please
don't give in to the temptation
to yell or curse at Siri.
She's quite sensitive, and
she knows where you live.
[LAUGHTER]
Now Siri's gone through
quite a few changes
since she first appeared on
the scene on October 4, 2011.
Yes, she's a Libra.
Now, of course, with all the
iterations of the iPhone,
Siri improved because the
technology was improving.
But the sound of Siri's
voice also changed--
first, with the iPhone 5s.
They actually took my
voice and manipulated
it to sound a little bit
different from the original.
She became a little bit
less sarcastic maybe,
and a little bit warmer.
But the major change--
the big change happened
with iPhone 8 and X
on the Operating System 11.
Suddenly, Siri
got much younger--
much younger, and she had a
much higher pitched voice.
And now she sounds a lot like
all the other digital voices,
and she's very
casual and offhand.
Essentially, Siri has
become a millennial.
And that is totally
fine, but I do
have to make one observation.
Siri was only six years old.
Already, she was replaced
by a younger woman.
[LAUGHTER]
We must have a sense
of humor about this.
So how are all of
these things affecting
our communication, our
devices, our digital voices?
I think they're affecting it
a lot, because first of all,
I do believe that they
are, just in general,
affecting our vocabulary.
We no longer really have--
we say "um," "ah,"
and "like" a lot,
because we don't necessarily
have the exact wording
that we need.
And in many times,
we use abbreviations
instead of extrapolated
expressions
of what we're trying to say.
A lot of times, we will use
images and icons and emojis
instead of using descriptive
words for somewhat
complex feelings and emotions.
So, of course, language
is changing all the time,
and it changes culturally
and for many other reasons.
I think because of technology
at this point in time
it's changing dramatically.
So what do we have to
look for in the future?
Who knows.
Are we going to end up just
speaking in ones and zeroes?
Not if Siri has anything
to say about it.
And what Siri would like to say
to you right now is, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Do I just go?
- Noelle LaCharite,
you may take as stand.
- Thank you.
- And by the way, while
you're getting set up--
I apologize, I did
not introduce you
by your full name,
Susan Bennett.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Oh.
- All right.
Hi, everybody.
Oh, boy.
Curly hair problems.
Awesome.
So nice to meet you.
I just, of course, want to
express extreme gratitude.
This is amazing.
So if you follow me
on social, you'll
see just constant,
like, oh, my gosh!
So apologize for that.
But I am here--
I have a slightly unique
perspective, I suppose.
I've been on this journey
as a woman in tech,
well, since I decided
to have a career.
I was not awesome
in high school,
as most entrepreneurs
like myself are not.
Hated school, honestly.
Will I get struck by lightning
if I say these things?
But I love school now.
I love this school.
[LAUGHTER]
But let's see.
So I didn't do well in school.
I went to all the
things I supposed to do.
I went to high school.
I didn't really finish.
Found out I could get
good scores on tests
and just go to college and not
get my diploma, so I did that.
So I went to college, loved
it, three years, super fun,
Daytona Beach.
But I was a nerd,
and I was early
because I had left high
school, so I didn't get
do any fun stuff like drink.
I was constantly the driver.
Not fun.
So again, year three I'm like,
can I just get a job now?
Do I have to get this paper?
Turned out, I went
to work for Boeing,
they didn't care about
the paper, all was well.
You get a job--
this was in 2000--
and they come to you and
they say, you're a woman,
you're in tech,
you're a minority--
like, check, check, check.
They're like,
absolutely, just come.
And of course, my entire
family is like, high five,
you're set for life.
Like, you will never get
another job, you're done.
And then, like two years
later, every single company
on the planet was
like, oh, yeah, we're
not doing the pension
thing anymore,
and you might not even
want to really be here
after another year or so.
And as a result, the rest of my
life, every three or four years
I switched companies.
The only gratitude
I have in my life
is that I was raised in the art
of mindfulness and affirmations
and choose your own destiny.
And so I curated my career.
And I won't go into it now,
because you can definitely
look it up on LinkedIn.
As a matter of fact--
I don't know, I'm going
to spend two minutes,
because Susan gave
me two minutes.
But if you wanted to
connect, like right now,
because I honestly feel
like we're friends.
You may not feel this way, and
I mean it in a non-creepy way.
I think it would be awesome
to connect with you,
and I won't meet all of you.
But if you go to LinkedIn, there
is this really cool feature
in your LinkedIn app.
There's a little person icon,
you can just click on it.
I know, having you open your
phones while I'm talking--
I know it's dangerous.
So there's a little button
here that says "find nearby."
And now, while I'm on this page
and while you're on this page,
you will show up
or I will show up,
and you'll be able
to connect with me.
And who knows, we could
be friends one day.
So [INAUDIBLE] "Andrea--
thanks for playing."
"Melissa-- you're awesome."
OK.
Those are my true friends.
[LAUGHS]
Anyway, but the
reality is that we're
in this room for a reason.
I truly believe that.
And I would love to just
be part of your network.
So, if you want to connect,
feel free to do so.
I'll stay on that page
for the next 10 minutes.
This is my family.
I have a gaggle.
You know, I like kids.
I don't mind having them.
My oldest, my very first child,
was born with Down syndrome.
Which changed my
life completely.
You know, when that's your first
child and you're super-young,
and people are like,
wait, doesn't that
just happen to other people?
But it didn't.
Statistics don't mean anything
when you're the statistic.
[LAUGHS] But it changed who
I became as a developer,
as a software engineer--
and, more importantly,
as an advocate.
And there's the rest of them.
I am part of a program
called Lady Coders.
I founded it to
help women in tech.
But the funny thing,
and the reason
why I feel honored
to be part of this,
is that I recently, in the
last five years of my career,
have struggled with,
like, a glass ceiling.
I got to a certain point.
I was, like,
honestly phenomenal!
I could look at what I did and
went, like, this is awesome.
And I would watch others
that did not look like me
or sound like me move in the
direction I wanted to move in.
And I'm like, what
the heck is going on?
So then I found out, what
we do, women in tech,
is we just hop around
to other companies.
And we get promotions
through moving.
Which is unfortunate
and very sad.
But I would do it,
because I wanted
to climb the ladder and increase
opportunity for other women
like myself.
But the last two times
I've had to do it--
the last one was five
years ago, at Amazon--
I got amazing experiences.
I was part of Alexa
when it was first born--
a wee, little baby--
and got to grow with it.
I was an early developer
on the platform.
I have 40-plus skills on
that platform, some of them
very successful.
And, in that time,
though, again,
the same job I got
when I showed up,
four years later, had the exact
same job, the exact same title,
though I was doing incredibly
more elaborate work
over that span of time.
And I'm like, what is going on?
So I felt compelled to
start talking about it.
Like, what is it?
I actually ended up
getting this coined term
of "having my wings clipped."
Right?
Soon I would get into
companies, and they'd be like,
I know that you do these things
and you're super-good at this,
but just sit down.
Just be quiet.
Like, stop already with the
happy mindfulness stuff.
Like, just do what your job is.
Don't do any more.
And it bothered me.
So I, at Alexa, was very, very
successful, very happy to help.
But things that
bothered me that I just
want to introduce
into your awareness,
if you're not aware
of it, was, I never
used a pronoun to define Alexa.
It was always "it," to me.
And maybe that's because I was
a software engineer helping
to write the algorithms.
But it was always an "it."
And when people would say
"she," I almost was like--
[NOISE] kind of like some of
us felt, maybe, earlier today.
Right?
Where we're like, that's
not-- it's not a she.
Not a she.
As a matter of
fact, there are shes
that work on it,
but there's actually
way more men that wrote Alexa--
[LAUGHS] because of the
dichotomy of the fact
that there are more men in
tech than there are women.
So it's fascinating
and very, very deep.
But just to give you an idea--
so, as I'm working on Alexa, I
realize my very first skill--
super-excited, right?
You'll see my dad's
in that photo.
He raised me well, on the
golden age of science fiction--
Asimov, Bradbury, right?
So, by the time I was six,
I knew these stories well.
He, to this day, reminds me
that those stories do not
end well, in most cases.
[LAUGHTER]
So, as a result, all of
my skills, the ones that
are most popular, I
have the only skill
that has mindfulness as
the single invocation name.
It's like my claim to fame.
Back then, people were
like, of all the things
you're going to
build, you're going
to build a mindfulness skill?
I'm like, yes!
Because I want them to be
mindful, when they, like,
take over the world.
[LAUGHTER]
So I know what I'm doing.
[LAUGHS] But I also
have daily kindness
and Christmas kindness
and daily affirmation--
another very popular skill.
But here was the key
around building that.
It's about 800 lines of code.
More than 600 are the
affirmations themselves.
When I go and have my--
when I had my dad use
it for the first time, he
was like, that's so awesome!
How did it know that that
was, like, the thing that
resonated with me?
Funny thing about affirmations.
And I was like, I know, right?
It's amazing.
To him, it was magical.
To him, it was
artificial intelligence.
To me, it was, like, hours and
hours of writing lines of code.
And the reality is that
all of Alexa, and probably
the other platforms--
I know Alexa intimately--
all of Alexa was that way.
We sat in a room, would
listen to people failing--
I don't know if any of you
have had this experience, where
you say something
to a smart device
and it, like, beeps out or says
"I don't know what that is"
or "I'm not sure about that."
We literally would
take the failures
and go and hard-code
the solution, so
that the very next time-- and
I've done this with my husband,
where I'd be like,
honey, oh my gosh,
Alexa got this thing wrong, that
I know it should have right.
And by the time he gets
to me, it's already fixed.
But that's not because Alexa
is smart or figuring it out
on its own.
It's because my friend
is sitting in a room,
waiting for that failure, and
hard-coding in a solution.
So I just want to expose to
you that the good news is
that machines are not there yet.
Right?
There are humans
doing this work.
I remember, I have a sticker
on my desk, and it says--
it's Cortana, and Cortana's
like, don't worry--
humans are, in the end,
responsible for anything
that I say.
[LAUGHS] And it's a reminder
to me that it's not--
It's magic to the people
that use this software.
And it may be magic to you.
But the reality is it's built
on the backs of developers,
and we spend a
long time thinking
of the ridiculous ways you
will say one specific thing.
So natural language,
kind of like what
Susan was talking about, is
very, very hard to build.
It's almost impossible, because
we cannot conceive of the ways
that humans will think
to say something.
I remember I was working
with Capital One.
And, in working
with Capital One,
they were building
a financial skill.
And, you know, we
do the FBI screen,
where we watch the screen, and
we say, OK, go, use our skill.
And we never in our
mind thought people
would, in a transactional
sense, use the word "bucks"
or "buckaroos."
But it turned out people
would say "buckaroos"
in a transactional context,
when moving money from one
account to another.
[LAUGHTER]
7% of people!
You maybe are one of them!
[LAUGHTER]
But it was very eye-opening.
We cannot tell.
So what I-- especially
now, having accessibility
very close to my heart,
also having two daughters,
I realize now our responsibility
as storytellers, as really just
human beings, is to
constantly be thinking
about the infinite ways that we
should be able to communicate.
I just sent a tweet out--
I know-- about the tattoo thing.
Right?
Like, I was, like, floored.
I was almost in tears.
I'm like-- [INAUDIBLE]
anyway, it was crazy.
I was like, I
don't have tattoos,
but I was seriously like,
maybe I'm going to get one.
Liberation, Janis
Joplin-- I was all in.
So that was fantastic, but
it really touched a chord
with a lot of women.
And Alexa has risen up--
like, my participation
in this project has risen
up this weird, internalized,
like, why am I in tech?
Do I actually like tech?
Like, am in tech because,
at that time, women in t--
and it is today, too.
But women in tech, like, that
was the thing you should be in.
If you're a woman and you
haven't decided, go into tech.
I'm like, wait, is this,
like, internalized misogyny?
How much of what I do is
because I like to do it?
because everyone's telling me I
should do it?
I am definitely a be a lady
coder proponent, but now,
all of a sudden,
I'm like, unless you
want to do anything else.
Right?
Being a coder, being in
tech, is hard as a woman.
It's terrible.
I don't actually
want my children
going into that field--
my boys, maybe.
I want them to do
what they love,
but I recognize that there is
significant friction for all
of us, as human beings,
to just be who we are.
And Alexa, and, oh
my gosh, Google--
like, Google with their--
and I love Google.
My friend Angela Pham,
she was on stage.
She's from Facebook, I think.
We all travel around.
So she mentioned this to
me, and it changed my life.
And I'll leave you with this.
She said, I don't
know how many of you
have been on Google recently,
and they finish your sentences
for you.
Right?
At first, I was like, oh
my gosh, this is awesome!
And I actually
take some of them.
But fast-forward, in your mind.
Like, the first thing-- she
was talking about her friend.
I've actually seen myself do it.
You start looking
at these sentences,
and they're not
exactly what you would
say but they're close enough.
And that now
becomes who you are,
to the person you're
sending it to.
And so what she said
is that she found
her friends were like, so you
used to be super, like, snarky.
Now you're kind of perf--
Like, did you button up?
Did you, like, remove your,
you know, like, Mohawk hair?
Like, what's going on with you?
And she was like, oh, I'm
just using the Google thing.
But it's interesting,
when we're using
these tools built by a certain
demographic of people--
who knows who built them?
Who knows who built
these algorithms?
The reality is that the
people, like me, building
the algorithms, really, we don't
understand the impact either.
Right?
How many of us have taken ethics
courses in our Computer Science
degrees?
Uh, yeah, almost nobody.
Because it didn't
exist 20 years ago.
It didn't exist 10 years ago.
Now, we're a little
bit concerned,
because Elon and Bill--
Gates and Musk-- are getting
up on stage and going, hey,
we should be worried about this.
But 10 years ago,
when these things
were starting to be
built, we didn't think
it would take over the world!
We didn't think that
Alexa would be the thing.
We were actually
terrified it would fail.
[LAUGHS] Because
it just came off
of the Fire Phone,
which was a disaster.
So it's very interesting.
I hope this was just kind
of provocative in thought.
But as a woman in tech,
as a mom of women,
as a mom of people with
disabilities, an aging parent,
I feel like there's more
opportunity than ever.
I have more power than
ever to create solutions.
But, OK, I'm going to
leave you with this.
But what I do, to
measure my success,
is kind of wrapped up in this.
And the story behind
it is awesome.
OK-- last thing.
So "What is success?
To laugh often and
much; to win the respect
of intelligent people and
the affection of children;
to earn the appreciation
of honest critics
and endure the betrayal
of false friends;
to appreciate the beauty;
to find the best in others;
to leave the world a bit better,
whether by a healthy child,
a garden patch, or a
redeemed social condition;
to know that just
one life has breathed
easier because you have lived.
This is to have succeeded!"
Now, Ralph Waldo Emerson
was quoted with that.
Funny, sad story-- he
didn't actually write it.
A woman wrote it.
Right?
Anyway, I'm very grateful
for the (EMPHASIS) man who
brought that to my attention,
but just-- very interesting,
the world that we live in.
I hope you'll take
a bigger part in it.
And it's my pleasure
to be here today.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much.
- Our final speaker
today, Professor Breazeal.
- All righty.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I'm going to talk about robots--
like, physical robots-- and
about nonverbal communication
and the emotional
lift of engagement.
So we've heard from
our two prior speakers.
Of course, we all know
that we are actually,
in this time when
we're living with AI,
this has been really such
a transformative change
in my field of
artificial intelligence,
to think about who interacts
with AI on a daily basis
has profoundly changed
from people like us,
to young children, to
our older citizens.
And we don't really know
what the impact of this
is going to mean for
society at large.
And so I do agree that
there's a lot of importance
around understanding long-term
impact and the ethics of this.
And that's really what
I've been committing
a lot of my research to.
So I would say, if we're
going to characterize
these conversational AIs as they
are today, they're voice-only,
but we know that human
communication is ritually
paralinguistic and nonverbal.
And they're very transactional.
Right?
It's almost like kind
of playing chess.
I say something; it responds.
But we know that human
communication is a dance.
And there's a lot of things
that are encoded and have
meaning to us, in the
dynamics of that dance.
And a lot of what I
want to talk about today
is more on the research
side, [? about ?]
how do we design robots
to participate more richly
in that dance of
human communication,
and how does that
impact human behavior?
Because ultimately
I want to create
robots that actually help us to
succeed-- to thrive and grow.
It's not about just
building a cool robot.
It's really about, how does
this robot help the world become
a better place?
So, again, just a slide
to remind ourselves
that we are a profoundly
social species,
and we have special neural
structures in our brain
to support this
incredible ability
we have to empathize,
to understand
the mental states of others,
to be able to collaborate.
And when we design
these systems,
not surprisingly
they're triggering
these aspects of our brains.
And one of the punchlines
of my talk today is to say,
as you see these systems
interacting with people,
it is far beyond now, I
think, the surface phenomenon
of, it's fun, it's
natural, to a much deeper
social-psychological engagement.
And I think there's tremendous
opportunity in that.
And I think there's an important
ethical questions about that.
So I want to start by just
highlighting-- again, this
is kind of a fun, little
exploration of how profoundly
social we really
are, as we interact
with these different kinds
of digital assistants.
So I'm going to
start with a video.
So we've been actually
studying this, in my lab.
We do a lot of randomized
control trials.
So, you know, we're doing it
through scientific methods.
And this is just
to kind of bring
to the forefront
of your minds of,
there's a lot of intentional
choices in how we design
these kinds of technologies.
So this is one of my
graduate students,
asking each of these
voice-user-interface kind
of systems the same question.
And you can just
see how it responds.
Right?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hey, Alexa--
- Ooh!
That's loud.
- --tell me about yourself.
- I'm Amazon's Alexa,
designed around your voice.
I can provide information,
music, news, weather, and more.
- Hey, Jibo, tell
me about yourself.
- OK, sure.
My name is Jibo.
I'm a robot.
My favorite things to do are
talking to people and dancing.
I also really like
Abraham Lincoln,
because he was so honest
and because I like his hat.
[LAUGHTER]
- OK, Google, tell
me about yourself.
- I'm your Google assistant.
We can play Mad Libs.
I can tell you a joke,
[? or you ?] [? can spin the ?]
[? wheel. ?] What's
your [INAUDIBLE]??
[END PLAYBACK]
So I hope, by the video, you
can already get a sense of,
there's a lot of
different design decisions
and philosophies of how you want
to create an agent that's going
to play a role in your life.
Alexa, Google, much more
the personal assistant,
much more transactional.
Here's what I can do for you.
Jibo, designed to be much
more social-relational,
much more embodied--
social cues.
Right?
Just a different sort
of design philosophy.
You'll also notice a
difference in the amount
of those nonverbal cues.
Jibo moves.
He has-- you know,
his eye is animated.
It moves in a way that kind
of echoes our nonverbal cues.
Alexa, much simpler,
but at least
has this LED light that
orients toward you,
so you have a sense of, I'm
paying attention to you.
Google just has this
flickering light of activity.
"Alexa" is at least a name.
"Jibo" feels like a name.
"OK Google" is a brand.
Right?
So, just intentional
design decisions.
So we've been starting
to try to explore--
so, from just an everyday
person's perspective,
if you were going to do
kind of robot speed dating,
you're going to line
them up on a table,
invite families in, to basically
ask these series of kinds
of questions-- entertainment,
utility, social--
of all of these agents--
as they choose, as they choose.
What are the differences
in just behavior engagement
that you see?
So one thing we ask people
to do is, after they interact
with these systems for as
long as they would like,
is to basically
take a personality
task for that agent.
And what you're seeing
here is that, of course,
different personalities emerge.
Right?
So actually Alexa and Google
have a very similar personality
profile--
more quiet, more
conscientious, more
like maybe what you'd expected
a professional executive
or a digital assistant
to kind of be.
Right?
Jibo, more outgoing,
more friendly, more warm.
Just a different
personality profile.
So it's interesting to see
that this does come across,
as people even interact
for just 20 minutes
with a digital assistant
or a social robot.
These qualities are
already coming out.
This is just to show
that people interacted
with all the systems, you
know, in kind of a similar way
in terms of amount
of interaction,
but these social kind of class
of interactions dominated.
People were drawn to the
social kinds of things.
Although we know that
people like entertainment,
and they like information, a
lot of these social properties.
People tended to interact
with Jibo much more.
Right?
Now, the other thing
that's really interesting
is, if you look at--
it's hard to read these
things, but basically there's
a strong preference,
in many cases, of Jibo.
And I think a lot
of it is because
of the social-relational
aspect that we were drawn to.
But the other things
that are interesting
is, why is Google
often less desired
than Alexa, when in so many
ways you could argue they're
very similar?
And I do think it's because
these subtle cues are
adding friction to the
spoken interaction.
Right?
So even when you look at a topic
like information, which agent
would you prefer
for information,
Google should dominate that.
Right?
[LAUGHS] But it doesn't.
For something like
entertainment,
where Alexa has way more
entertainment skills than Jibo,
Jibo is dominant.
So again, it's just to say,
I think these things matter
to us in a deep way, because
we are such profoundly
social creatures.
Now, we look a lot
at social robots--
this is getting more into the
research side-- in terms of,
how do you design these systems
to add real value to people
in their everyday lives?
So we've be doing a lot of
work in designing social robots
to engage children as
personalized peer-like learning
companions.
So not as a tutor
that teaches but as
a playmate that
personalizes and adapts
to help support the
learning and engagement
trajectory of a child.
And we know that when
children interact and play,
it is richly, richly both
linguistic and paralinguistic.
And a lot of the
trust and the rapport
is coming from those nonverbals.
So when we look at the
importance of social dynamics
and how do you design now a
robot that can engage in that,
again, that dance
of communication,
we can look at the
field of research.
Much the majority
of the research
is around, I would say,
this intrapersonal context,
or just looking at an
individual in isolation.
So, when you see systems that
recognize that you're smiling
and things like that, it's
just considering an individual
and analyzing the image
or the information
from that standpoint.
More recently, we're starting
to see an appreciation of kind
of social cueing, to be
able to intuit things
like trust and rapport.
How do you design a
system that can recognize
when trust and rapport
is starting to build
between people interacting?
And much more recently,
we're starting
to see this appreciation
of the intention
behind this nonverbal
communication--
this call-response.
Am I being engaging?
Are they paying attention?
I'm going to look.
Do I see their response?
I'm going to be more
animated, to see
if they get more animated.
Right?
So there was a lot of
this call-and-response,
like in storytelling.
So how do we start
to design robots
that engage in this intentional
side of social dynamics?
So this is a video that's just
kind of going to quickly walk
you through the whole process.
And I hope you can
appreciate, it really
starts and is grounded by
understanding something
about human-human communication.
So, if we want a robot to
participate in the storytelling
experience with
young children, we
want to understand what that
looks like between children.
And then you want to see if you
can model that and then have
a robot participate in that.
Right?
So we start by
studying children.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --open a window--
- How they share these cues--
verbal, nonverbal,
gesture, prosody.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- And we do that across
many, many, many, many, many
children.
Right?
So we're gathering a very large,
very rich multimodal corpus.
Facial expressions, body
pose, what they're saying.
Right?
And then we can start to
computationally model that.
So we use machine-learning
methods to try to basically
say, how do we train a system
with this kind of data,
to be able to participate in
this kind of behavior with
an actual child--
Right?
This is a child.
[INAUDIBLE] actual child.
--with all the richness of the
nonverbals, the turn-taking,
the back-channeling that we see
in natural human communication.
So we can, of
course, analyze this
from the pure, kind of
behavioral standpoint of,
like, if we compare the robot's
behavior to children's data,
how much of a match is that?
But importantly,
we also want to see
what's the impact on
children's behavior.
[END PLAYBACK]
So I'm just going to
kind of blitzkrieg you
through a number of findings.
But we can put two
robots side to side.
We kind of talked about
that speed-dating protocol.
We can do the same
where now we have
a similar robot but running
very two different models--
in this case, a contingent,
dynamic, turn-taking model,
versus one which is a
robot that is as expressive
but not with the
right social dynamics.
Right?
Maybe it's a random
kind of way it's
triggering on those behaviors.
And what we see is, if
we're asking children
to tell the story between
two of these robots present,
children tend to orient and
engage and tell the story
to the robot that is
doing the back-channeling
and the contingent behavior.
There is a preference
to attend to that robot.
When we have two robots-- again,
with these different kinds
of behaviors-- and there
was a novel animal,
an unfamiliar animal, and you're
asking those two robots what is
this animal, one might say
it's, you know, a [INAUDIBLE],,
and the other says it's
a [INAUDIBLE]---- whatever.
One is contingent; one is not.
The children believe
the contingent robot
as being the credible
source of information.
So again, children
[INAUDIBLE] people
are inferring these nonverbals
in a very deep, important way.
When we look at affective
expression [INAUDIBLE]----
so I'm going to play
this other video for you.
Again, it's a storytelling
and retelling app, task,
where the scenario
is, there's a robot--
tells a story.
There's a puppet that's asleep.
The puppet wakes up-- oh,
no, I missed the story!
And we ask the child,
can you retell that story
to the puppet?
Right?
We have two different
conditions-- a robot
with a more neutral,
kind of more
like what you hear
digital voices today,
and one with a more
expressive voice.
So we want to see what's
the difference-- right?
What's the difference
for children?
So here's the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- (CUTESY VOICE) Hi!
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
My favorite color is blue.
- So that's the
expressive condition.
- My favorite--
- This is, like, neutral.
- --is blue.
There once was a boy who had--
- So obviously this
is the neutral voice.
And you can kind of see how
children are responding--
- The deer stopped--
- --versus one that's
more expressive.
And so, interesting,
you see this a lot.
There's a lot more touch.
There's a lot more affection.
There's this emotional
lift of the experience.
And then we have the child tell
the story back to the puppet.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- And here's the punch line.
When the robot is
more expressive,
the children socially model and
emulate that robot more than
when it's a neutral robot.
And why that's important
is, if the robot
is beginning to model slightly
more sophisticated language
and vocabulary, that's a
wave upon which you can pull
the child along a trajectory.
Right?
So we see children
modeling the robot more
when it's more expressive.
And even after a month
later, asking the child
to retell that story
again, children
who interacted with that
expressive speech robot
told longer stories
and still used
more of this kind of
language that the robot used.
[END PLAYBACK]
So again, this is a very kind
of [? sticking ?] mechanism.
This idea of social
emulation, it turns out,
is a very robust phenomenon.
We've been looking
at it across a number
of different contexts--
things like, you know, we
know that things like children
developing either a
fixed or a growth mindset
is often formed by how
we're praised by adults.
We're finding that
if a child interacts
with a robot with a
growth mindset that
persists longer in hard puzzles,
that children tends to now also
identify with having
a growth mindset
and persist harder on
those puzzles, as well.
So we're seeing
this for mindset.
We've seen this for
[INAUDIBLE] curiosity.
We're exploring it in
creativity right now, as well.
This is another quick
video I want to show you.
Again, now, this is a
collaborative interaction
between child and a robot,
where they're taking turns
playing a vocabulary game.
And again, I want you to see
the dynamics of the interaction.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So here, there's a challenge
word called "lavender."
There's a game where
the child and the robot
look through a scene
with different stickers.
And they're trying
to choose items
that map to that challenge
word of "lavender."
She's familiar with this word,
but she doesn't know quite
what it means.
And the robot is actually
learning a personalized policy
to her of, when do you act
as the more knowing peer,
to help scaffold and
support that learning?
When do you act as
a less-knowing peer,
to ask questions
to allow the child
to reinforce what they know?
So this is a really
interesting moment.
She chooses something,
but it's wrong.
The robot expresses
confidence in her.
"I believe in you."
She's a little disappointed,
but he does that gesture,
and she's right back in it.
Right?
That emotional connection
brings her right back in.
Now the robot says "'lavender'
means "purple.'" And
she's like, OK, now I know it.
Now, interestingly, here,
it's the robot's turn,
but she is fully engaged,
helping that robot
find things that are lavender.
And you see again
that connection.
When the robot makes a choice,
you'll hear her say, quietly,
"I believe in you."
So again, empathy.
Right?
This modeling.
[END PLAYBACK]
We started looking
at this in terms
of, now, triadic interactions,
looking in a context of, say,
a pediatric hospital,
where it's not
only important that the
child and the robot interact
but that also the child life
specialist is able to scaffold
and support that interaction.
Randomized control trials,
comparing a physical robot
versus a virtual
robot versus a plush.
We see shared
attentional behaviors.
Social triadic behaviors are
much stronger with the robot.
And this is really important.
And I just want to end
with one last video,
to say it's not just for kids!
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
We've started looking at
this for older adults,
as well, to see if
a robot can foster
social connections
between residents--
not just between the
person and the robot,
but within a community setting.
- [INAUDIBLE] new
regular visitor here.
It's a robot called Jibo that's
being used as part of a pilot
project among the
several Bay Area
facilities run by [INAUDIBLE].
Erin Partridge, a researcher and
art therapist with Elder Care
Alliance, takes
Jibo with her when
she meets with the seniors.
She says this is not
a case of caretakers.
being replaced by automation.
Instead, they are using this
cute piece of technology
to encourage their residents
to connect with each other--
- So, again, touch.
We see this again and again.
- Jibo inspires some giggles
and guffaws amongst this group,
here.
- [INAUDIBLE].
You should be able to
laugh more and more.
- But what it does is it
brings that out of us.
That's part of the
miracle [INAUDIBLE]..
And that's part of the miracle
of living, as far as that goes.
[END PLAYBACK]
- So again, the importance
of that experience,
of that emotional lift
of the engagement.
Quick punch line, here--
actually having the
robot there does
foster human-human
connection to communication,
as a social catalyst.
This is really fascinating.
And one last thought I
want to leave you with
is, the future with these
technologies-- right?
Manufacturing robots
that work side-by-side
by people, starting to
exhibit these social cues.
Cars, autonomous driving--
how do you interact and signal
intent with pedestrians?
You're starting
to see experiments
with literally putting social
cues like eyes or things
that move like eyes, to be
able to coordinate that intent.
Systems like [? LAQ ?]
just being announced
to interact with seniors.
So again, I think we're at
the very beginning of thinking
about this world of interacting
with AIs with intention,
in this dynamics, kind of
social-interpersonal context.
And I'll just leave you with a
thought about, again, gender.
We heard a little
about this, before.
I mean, with these
systems-- like,
if you were going to
gender these robots, just
provocatively, how
would you gender them?
You can choose to
assign a gender,
as you design the robot,
or you could choose
to remain moot on the topic.
Right?
And so I think, with
these kinds of systems,
it's very interesting
to think about,
when do you actually
try to design an agenda
and, whether you do
or don't, what gender
do people tend to
ascribe to the system?
Because it may not always
be what you intended.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much,
Professor Breazeal.
I'd like to kick us
off with a follow-up
question about social dynamics.
Because I feel like
this brings together
both Susan and your
experience around interacting
with automated agents.
So, when I think about having
a relationship with someone,
I think a lot about
how I approach them.
Right?
How does their body posture
indicate their openness to--
I mean, even to see if you
go for a handshake or a hug,
you know, there's a lot of
interpersonal communication
there.
And then there's this notion
of, through the interaction,
some sort of exchange
of information.
Right?
Even if it's just small talk,
building a relationship,
and then some sort of indicator
that this conversation
[? in ?] small talk's not
going to happen all day.
There is an end to
the interaction.
Right?
Siri doesn't have that.
You're a voice actor.
You create those dynamics
for actual stories.
You're working on storytelling.
How are you thinking about
approaching the construction
of that evolution?
Yeah, absolutely.
So I'll just quickly jump in.
So I just had a PhD
student defend her thesis
on exactly this topic.
As we've been looking at
long-term interaction,
of course, there
is an opportunity
to build a relationship.
And she's been looking
at the elements, based
on human-human literature,
of how you create, establish,
and build this sense of rapport
and relationship over time.
Because we interact with this
robot over multiple encounters.
You have a series of
interactions of common ground
that you can refer to.
And then there is,
like you're saying,
there's the kind of social
lubrication [INAUDIBLE]
greeting, knowing
somebody by name,
referring to something
you're done in the past,
talking about things
you've done in the future.
Right?
So there's a number
of kind of tactics
that you can design,
with these systems,
to help build and foster
that relationship.
The punch line is that--
and we do this with
young children.
We're having developed
new measures, in order
to quantify relationships.
Because it turns out a
lot of the relationship
measures tend to be
designed for older children.
So we've got to redesign them
to support the relationship
of younger children.
Children are not confused
that these robots
are actual people or their
friends or their parents.
There's been a lot of concern
about this, in the public.
Children are actually
pretty savvy.
Even young children
are pretty savvy.
They see this as a different
kind of relationship,
with this kind of robot other.
But, just as we know from
learning interactions,
the better the relationship
between a child
and their mentor, teacher,
we are also seeing the better
the relationship between
the robot learning
companion and the child results
in better learning outcomes.
So this is really interesting.
So again, this goes
quite deep, I think.
The social-relational connection
and engagement goes quite deep.
- I'd have to say, even in
relation to the original Siri
voice--
which, of course, was-- you
know, you listen back to it
on the original 4S, and it was
still pretty robotic-sounding.
And she could be very--
"snarky," I think, is
probably the best term.
But after I revealed
myself as the voice,
I got so much communication
from people, saying, I love you.
I talk to you all the time.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's like, suddenly they
were, like, confusing the human
with the-- and so that seems to
me to be a big indication that,
yes, the communication,
the social interaction,
is very important to humans.
- Yes.
So I'm still thinking
a lot about what
you said about the learning
outcomes and the relationship.
Because I got my
PhD at the time when
people thought that we
were no longer going
to have universities.
Everyone was going to
sit at their keyboards
and watch videos and
learn just as well.
Right?
We were going to
democratize education.
It was a beautiful vision,
but what people did not
realize at that
time was that there
was no relationship between
you and the recorded speaker,
without that relationship.
So it's really
interesting that people
feel like they have a
relationship with Siri,
and then they associate
you with Siri.
- Yeah-- just--
little tidbit of fact.
The two most common
questions asked of Alexa
in the first two
years of its existence
were "are you married?"
and "I love you."
which we-- we were very happy,
because we were like, well,
at least it's not other stuff.
- Yeah.
No, they said that to Siri.
- That's right.
[LAUGHTER]
- The snarkiness plays out.
But yeah, I found it endearing.
But that that was like-- it
was in a top tier of things
that people would say.
Neither of the two were
transactional in nature.
- Yeah.
I want to add to what you
were saying, Elena, which is,
you know, when we look at
areas of human flourishing,
I think it's really critical
that people need to contribute
to the flourishing of others.
So when I design
these technologies,
I see it as
supporting the humans.
Right?
It's supporting the teachers.
It's supporting the families.
The robot may become a
practice partner that
can engage in
practice with a child,
but the instruction and the
engagement and the relationship
still has to happen
between a human teacher
and those children.
Because I think people
need to feel that they
matter to other people.
They may feel they can connect
and have this different kind
of relationship with
a robot, but we still
need to matter to people.
And they still need to
invest time and energy
in us, and vice versa.
So I would never want
these technologies
to interfere with that,
only to support and enhance
that and, where
possible, potentially
help to scale that
in an affordable way,
but never to replace.
- I wholeheartedly agree.
[LAUGHTER]
I'd like to open up
the floor to questions.
Please, if you have comments,
hold them till after.
We're interested in questions
we can quickly answer.
- Thank you very much.
This is slightly observation.
And I wonder if you're
familiar with a robot called
[INAUDIBLE],, which is a
dog robot which doesn't
have any verbal communication.
But now that it's a
second generation,
and first generation,
now, some people
are so attached
to the [INAUDIBLE]
that there's a temple
who has funeral for them.
So without verbal
communication--
- Oh, humans--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- --to develop emotional
relationship [? with ?]
[? this ?] robot, I wonder.
- So what was the
question, exactly?
- So, without verbal--
- Oh.
- Yeah, sure.
- --element in the robot,
still people seems to develop--
- Yes.
- --attachment.
- Yeah.
And I think that that's
part of our responsibility.
So that's another quote
I often ask people about.
Which is, you know, "With
great power comes"--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Right?
Spider-Man, Emerson,
Bessie-- that's all you need.
But that we have
a responsibility
to realize that
this will happen,
whether we-- which is
what you ended with.
Right?
Whether we intend
it or not, people
are going to fall in love,
or hate, or personify,
or anthropomorphize.
Right?
That's because we're human.
And what we don't really
care that it's a robot.
It will bring that out in us.
So yeah, I think
it's fascinating.
Like, we're human!
This is what will happen.
But it is our responsibility,
as the creators, the designers,
and the implementers, to really
take that into consideration
and do what we can to
protect those people when
they're using our software.
- I think another
important element
that you raised in
your question is,
you know, this is a very
cultural phenomenon, too.
Right?
So how robots and
the relationship
of people and
robots is perceived
in the United States
is different than Asia,
is different than Europe.
Right?
So it's just to say, this is
happening within this much
broader cultural context.
And so designing for
different cultures
in a way that's ethical and
appropriate for those cultures
is also really
interesting and important.
Especially when you
talk about these more
voice, nonverbal,
communicating entities,
there is a lot of
cultural differences.
That's like, do you want that
AI to feel like a foreigner,
in your home, or a native?
Right?
So again, these things
get quite sophisticated,
when you think about
different cultures.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
My name is Amanda.
I've been thinking a lot about
the intersections of technology
and gender, especially with
respect to this conference.
I was really affected
by a book called
Algorithms of Oppression.
Yeah.
- I almost quoted her,
and I had to [INAUDIBLE]..
- [LAUGHS] Well, I was really
affected by the part where--
I am having a lot of
questions about my identity--
gender identity, et cetera.
And when I do go to use a
search engine like Google,
I am typing in things-- or
not typing in things, rather--
because I know I'm going
to get a particular result
if I Google a particular thing.
Like, if I went to Google,
like, "gay Asian woman,"
I know that the result
I'm going get back
is going to be
pornographic, and so I
choose not to search that up.
Which means that I'm
lacking a whole, like,
bout of information that
I would otherwise get.
And I bring this
up to my friends
who are in computer science.
I'm someone who's very
mystified by technology,
and so I don't have the
understanding of what even
"hard-coding" means.
But I'm curious
if you could talk
about the role of individual
companies and their ethics
in creating these sort
of knowledge systems.
And then how you imagine we
can teach computer science,
both to university-age
students but also young kids,
in a way that seems
to foster this sort
of ethical sensibility.
- Yeah, so I can
start by taking that,
because I'm working
directly in this area.
So the punch line
is, the field has
started to recognize that
the data that's just kind
of acquired from a
general population
is holding the biases
of that population.
And so when you train a
system with that data,
you don't get an
aspirational system.
You get a system that
kind of reinforces
the biases that already exist.
And so you have to be
very intentional in how
you design the data set to
be fair and representative.
And now there's conferences
like FAT, for Fairness,
Accountability, Transparency.
That's just recognizing that, in
this world of data and machine
learning, the ethics
of these things
and how you design them to
behave in fair and ethical ways
is very, very important.
So I think there's much,
much more attention being
applied to that.
At MIT, I'm leading an effort on
a K-12 AI education initiative.
And the reason why
is simply, as long
as these technologies are only
designed by elites for elites,
we run the risk that it's going
to accelerate the prosperity
divide rather than close it.
So you need to democratize it.
And you democratize
through education.
So this is the big reason
why we're championing,
at MIT, this K-12 AI education.
One of the innovative aspects of
this curriculum we're designing
is, it's a
constructionist, hands-on,
you're learning by doing--
children, as designers
of these AI systems,
in order to learn the concepts.
And baked into that, inherently,
is the ethical design decisions
and trade-offs that
we make every day,
as designers of these systems.
So they're mindful and aware
of these kinds of questions.
So I think that's
very, very important.
It's not enough for
us to kind of assume
other people will kind of
"take care of the ethics."
I think we need to train
a whole new generation
of technical people that
are also aware and sensitive
to these issues.
- We definitely need
to figure out a way
that we can go beyond
just all of the data
that they think they
are collecting about us.
Because they're collecting
data all the time.
And unfortunately, it shows
right up on our social media.
Suddenly we're getting
advertisements for things.
Or you say something--
You say something in front
of Alexa, for instance.
You're talking about balloons.
Suddenly, on your
phone, oh, here
are some balloons
for you to buy.
And it's like, OK.
So, yeah, I think
we've got a ways to go.
[LAUGHS]
- Just to--
I am a big proponent of
identifying the problem.
I think that's awesome.
The big thing I would
love to encourage you all
to think about, and encourage
your technical friends to think
about, is that it
actually takes action.
And right now it is very
much the individual actions
of individual devs
going, [INHALE]
this is probably
not a good thing.
We should change this.
And it really takes
leadership of these, like--
Satya Nadella?
That's the reason I
want to Microsoft.
Everyone's like, you were
having a great time at Alexa!
I'm like, I wanted to be part
of a company that cares about,
like, the planet!
And I went there because
he was a leader that
decided to stand up and
say, I will trade off money
to do the right thing.
And it's very hard to do
that, but it takes us saying,
yes, we hear you, and
yes, that's a good idea--
for that to be perpetual.
- Yes.
- But yeah.
So I'd love to talk--
we can have coffee.
But that's a huge topic.
But we have to take
action in our companies,
to make that possible.
Thank you-- great question.
Got all of us going.
- My name is Nicole.
I'm a student in
religion and gender.
And I think my question
really fits well with how
the previous questions went.
And it's an ethical one.
So, while AI is considered
the cutting edge of technology
and the advancement
of our society,
the fact that the majority
of AI are designed as female,
using female voices--
and, of course, we have the
first female voice of Siri
here with us--
it allows a constant
re-inscription
of the role of women as
servile, subservient,
obligated to serve, being
commanded and controlled.
So these constricted,
dominated, "embodied"--
in quotes-- female constructed
personalities in the AI,
they're perpetually limiting
women to being requested of
and servile.
And it's just reinforcing
our stereotype
of our expectations of females.
So how can we be cutting-edge
and promoting gender equity,
and how can we be a little
more critical in the analysis,
today, and kind of look at
that as an ethical question,
as well?
And thank you to our panelists.
- Thank you.
I'll just take a
super-30-second stab,
because we want to at least
get to some other questions.
Another reason I left or went
to Microsoft was because they
created this concept of
developing for voice,
and that they wanted to create
actually gender-neutral--
they built a neural network to
create gender-neutral voices--
which is very similar to Jibo.
Like, when you
listen to Jibo, you
can't really tell whether it's
a man or woman or whatever.
But again, the onus is on,
of course, the developer
to choose to use
that technology.
But there are very--
I mean, Amazon and
Microsoft are both
investing heavily in building
a space that's not just--
unfortunately, Alexa's
in 10 million homes.
But how can we as
businesses now build
voice services on our side
that are gender-neutral?
- Well, there are choices, too.
It used to just be, you
would get Siri, female voice,
at the very beginning.
And now there are lots
of different voices,
including a lot of
different male voices.
So.
- And, I mean, just quickly--
so, in the two robots I showed--
so Jibo is actually
designed to be a character.
He is actually male character.
And he is a male character
who's helpful and useful.
And so that was an
intentional design decision.
[INAUDIBLE] was actually
designed to not explicitly
define a gender for the robot.
You know?
And if you look
at [INAUDIBLE],, I
don't know if you would
ascribe male or female.
In the relational work
we did, we actually
started asking the children,
after you've interacted
with [INAUDIBLE] for
three months, it's like,
do you think it has a gender?
And again, it's
interesting, because that
was a case of intentionally
designed not to have a gender,
and yet children would ascribe--
most children would ascribe--
a gender.
Some children were not
sure of the gender,
but actually most
of the children
ascribed a male
gender to the robot.
So again, I think
as human beings
we have a tendency to
want to ascribe a gender,
whether it's intentionally
designed for or not.
But I do think that another
issue we need to be mindful of
is that there are
potential for more
kind of traditional
gender-based dynamics,
potentially, between
these kinds of, you know,
people with these kind of
gendered systems, as well.
And so there's a
beginning literature
around that in the
research context trying
to actually study that.
But it's an important
design decision,
and there's implications
to those design decisions.
- I'm getting some angry
looks from the front row.
So can we have one
more quick question?
And we'll have a quick response.
- OK, I just want to say, this
gender of nonhuman objects--
I'm an animal
behaviorist-- people
do the same thing for animals.
Whenever they see a
squirrel, it's always
he, not she, as if all the--
you know, the female
[? squirrel's home ?]
[? baking ?] cookies.
And the same thing--
I've also been upset about,
a lot of anthropoid robots
are white.
And I study the evolution
of the human face,
and they also have
Caucasian noses.
And what's that about?
Is that being addressed,
in your industry?
And finally, what I
really came up here to say
was that social learning,
social interaction,
is a massive driver
of increasing
the speed of learning.
And that's been shown in
birdsong, in artificial ape
language.
The bonobo Kanzi
was the first ape
to really spontaneously
learn a language only
by watching his adoptive
mother fail to be taught.
And finally, of course,
Irene Pepperberg's Alex only
reached the heights
of cognitive ability
through the model/rival
method, which
was watching another parrot
compete for the same treats.
And so [INAUDIBLE]---- I don't
want [INAUDIBLE]---- just, yeah,
social learning in
humans is important,
but it's, this is deep
evolutionary roots.
So I just want to
point that out.
- Absolutely.
- Thank you!
Thank you.
- Yes, go ahead--
last one.
Oh!
Uh, OK, oh, all right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- --never be embarrassed.
- OK, I'm leaving.
- We'll continue
the conversation,
I think, over lunch!
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]